so basically I'm talking about
computation Jokke this is an idea I
presented to previous years on it and
you know a lot of times when you're
using Mathematica and and such a lot of
times you're trying to Colonel you have
to abort the kernel it's freezing you
know a lot of the time and you're like
this waste depends on how fast the
computer is probably but um I know when
you go to see a deejay and they're
mixing you know started in the 70s with
um like disco and hip-hop and everything
the DJ will go from one track to another
but they never drop the beat you know
they never say oh I got a bought the
kernel guys just you know wait a minute
you know what I mean you hang out on the
dance floor here studio you know studio
wherever and so anyway I thought why
can't we do the same thing with
computation you know especially when
you're teaching a class being a teacher
I know a lot of times the kids will be
all ready to learn you got 30 minutes
and then the teacher says you know let
me find my PDF and then they're like
bending over looking for the PDF for
like two minutes and then I said let me
find it at an MOV file and then they're
looking for the MOV file by the time
they find dude for I find three files
the computers crash they've they've
looked for everything in all their
folders I thought why can't you DJ a
lesson and that was one idea DJ a lesson
but why can't you also make then I
thought why can't it so you could you
know on these buttons you know normally
when you have a DJ they press it when I
say Flavor Flav or something when I
press the different samples I wanted to
be like you load your PDF and then you
know you can scratch and do like when
you go when you push it up the PDF will
go you know one page forward you do a
back scratch the PDF will go one
backwards then you can you know mix go
from your PDF to your MOV and then go to
a simulation and I basically started
like developing this idea more I thought
why can't we just make an interactive
I'll take all the mathematics that's
what brought me to Wolfram and the stack
of their building is that basically they
try to eat all treat all data types and
data is
first-class citizens that are you know
all interconnected and equivalent so
these are just some of the previous
talks I did last two years I'm showing
different things I was using on a chaos
pad to control XY grids and basically
just talking about different years so we
were supposed to be showing this on my
wave did just put a Bluetooth which I'm
a just a pain I'm just gonna take it off
but unfortunately the we weren't able to
get that on there was a major part but
the UM the Bluetooth just wasn't working
this is probably well show later but so
today would you like to have any arm any
volunteer anybody want to be a doing
view volunteer or anybody want to come
up we basically need someone to do it so
anyone want Valen Valen tier-i
we also I'm switching the picture just
do a regular one that looks pretty
normal right so yeah we're not really
exactly gonna be scratched
hey it is changing blue so if you see a
changing blue yeah I'm brain dead
probably so that blue color at least
something on something is changing
that's a proof of concept thanks to Todd
Gailey we made it flash blue brace on
our thoughts but in the future what I
want to be is like pulling a Mandelbrot
set like take the fractal dimension like
z22 you know all the way to Z to the 8th
and map my eg frequencies and then I
even want to try and trigger like I
could maybe in my mind I think and that
load seat you know rule 30 things are in
my mind it just you know puts out like Y
to the 2nd + 3 or something I was like
and pulling like scalars and everything
with my mind so this blue you know this
is like when um they looked at the moon
before they went to the moon basically
this is this alright so so as you can
see um we have these controls this is a
standard DJ mixer and you see these are
different rules of stephen wolfram
elementary CA so the seat of size can be
changed on there so let's see just make
it a little bigger so as you can see you
can control it so basically we mapped
the first 127 elementary CAS onto the
onto the board so we basically want kids
to be able to have you know like we have
the EEG they could have the control
boards and interface um I did and one of
my previous talks to last year we showed
how we can take CAS and fractals and put
them in one interactive environment you
know I want to take anything
from computational Sciences and
mathematics and and put them together
did you want to be the just play with
this and then I know it's like kind of
simple for you but I guess you can just
play with the and actually why are you
pressed number one when he presses
number one look he's a Julia set now
so actually he's maybe just do one and
two because I'll change it sorry
so this is actually changing the
imaginary and real coordinates so you
saw by pressing a button we went from
fractals
we went from CAS or fractals and that
that inner part was supposed to be
changing based on the EEG so now I'm
going to put on a little bit of effects
this looks at normal and only came in it
looked a little trippy so I'm gonna put
on as a feedback effect let's see see so
and then you can you see what I'm saying
you can do something like kind of wick
it with it like yeah so I'm doing a
little bit extra stuff here like you see
it just analog so I want to be able to
do the signal processing like like the
visualization and shoddy scheme and
everything and all the causation see
this is external I want to be able to do
stuff like that but then pull it out in
stereoscopy
so I mean you can see it looks kind of
weird but you can kind of see what I'm
trying to do so I'm doing keying
basically see we got the the keying
there and
[Music]
yeah so I think I think something might
have gotten I'm okay so let me um let me
go - let me go to another arm another
sighs oh oh here we go
okay music it is something is going on
with it but you can kind of see like in
the future we'd be pulling it all out
and getting it as funky as we see it
looks high like smoke right looks like
digital smoke and seem Co sort of
layering it's like I don't know if you
can kind of get what I'm saying I know
I've been doing this for a minute so
let's go to the other side Thank You
Todd
[Applause]
so now we go back to the slides and so
these were just some of the things I was
using to get the feedback and all that
and basically in the future we want to
here have it on full IMAX so what I
looked it up with them
I was talking to Nvidia and IMAX and
they're actually interested in part both
them are interested in partnering with
them wolfram and we want to I looked it
up with GPU and high-performance CPUs
and such it's a hundred percent possible
to do it have a kid have all these stuff
they could be in front of the imax
like when they make those movies for
Marvel and and um Black Panther and all
that they all cost you know hundreds and
millions of dollars but a kid could just
have you know an Arduino as long as we
had the GPU and CPU unit there in the
IMAX theater they could just bring their
laptop and plug it in and I think we
could just have plug and play with
Raspberry Pi and such and they could be
using Potts potentiometers or DJ
controls and I'm thinking like you give
them something like exoplanets they
could be getting data from you know
somewhere they can get particle physics
getting something from Cagle and be
parsing these large data sets and make a
artistic showed we just had a simple
Julia set with feedback but what I want
it to be is like they're like and then
it could play on it too they could you
know take a fractal shoot it into a CA
you know and I want to take all day
topic so you had a curve I'm based on a
3d plot of a function you could drag in
a um gif and put it on and map it onto
the surface then you could have little
matrix operators and um you could be
dragging and they could be doing linear
algebra you could have links to all of
your Wolfram documentation so they could
actually be playing with it and reading
documentation at once if they stated
getting something from Riemann and there
you know some of their reasoning you
know like a Riemann sphere or something
then they could look at the lineage you
know of um of our mathematics lineage
pages that they got and while they're
playing and experimenting with anything
in a computational field with no legs
what's the last part everybody um
everyone has their own opinions when you
have whenever you have a um like you
vote for somebody like one day voted
from President Trump and Hillary some
people wanted here Lee some people
wanted Trump it's just like Pepsi and
Coke you know I mean like people wanted
different things so in a democracy but
like let in democracy the people like
let's say there was like three people
wanted to kill another person that's
democracy right you could it'd be like
what we do something like that just like
cut their head off or something so
sometimes mock democracy might not be
fair to the little guy right so maybe
everyone can have their own universe so
basically could we like press a button
like how is loading different samples
and like you're watching TV trans
president you just press a button now
Hillary is president but I'm not like
I'm not saying in a simulation unless
you treat a universal simulation you
press another button kool-aid man you
know hey like we gotta got fiscal
responsibility or something like you
know Felix the Cat you know what I mean
we could have with Wolfram could be
president or we could change Wolfram
skin green we could take George Clinton
and Stephen Wolfram and make some like
DNA wise into like one creature and like
put like 15 of them just like in
space-time that's what I want my angle
to be to DJ anything in space-time like
let's say you're at a party and like
like you have 50 people you can be
having a slider like to the left 50 of
them are Chinese to the right 50 of them
are afro-american you go to the middle
25 and 25 you just DJing you know in
space and time you're your party so
could we do that I came up with the
axiom system to just kind of test it so
I'm not really like a teacher in an
artist so you know I'm not you know very
skilled and coming up with axiom systems
for first principles of mathematics and
cosmology but basically I I just posit
this on seven axiom group so could it be
that grand unified field theory the
fundamental replicator
of like the universe the see a recursive
function the fractal recursive function
and a primal feedback system we got on
Einstein you know I'm Darwin Wolfram
Mandelbrot Norbert Wiener maybe it's all
one on formula and this is what I posit
it is I'm basically based on these seven
axioms so my goal now is to formalize
these seven axioms because I think I
just believe that they give a you know a
formal binary decomposition which of the
universe and you know it might sound
weird but you know I really do believe
it you can get the notebook if you want
to look at it I'm trying to take seven
axioms i defined in a human language and
convert them into the logical language
Stephen was talking about this is a
variation on a model if with absolute
seven axiom but with this decomposition
I actually can generate sierpinski a
Pascal's triangle which um with um just
items from that um from the axiom system
and so from what comes out of it and
actually do the polynomial description
too I forgot to include here's just some
drawings this is basically about the
statistic that I think is non-trivial
which is key to the axiomatic scheme so
basically it has something called you
everyone know about self similarity but
I have an axiom called self similarity
co l /f and basically like that's I'm
just positing it if you if you if you
think it's BS you can try and test it or
you know write to me and basically if
that's all anybody you have any
questions yeah um I guess I can go over
them so and I'm going to say I'm in
human language so just some you know
this is just my attempt you know as an
artist and teacher to try and come up
with an idea so basically the universe
exists so you just probably universities
this and that is that it has enough on
variation you know to that we're trying
to basically just generate so basically
other universes this we can say that the
number two that it has a finite
beginning so we're working with I'm a
discrete system so already you know
people might have
whatever you think the universe is a you
know can completely continuous on its
nature three is that we take on the
Euclid's definition of a line segment so
this is describing in a human language
but basically I'm trying to you know
formalize these and look at them in my
next year
so basically did a fundamental recursive
operation I know some people you know
with relativistic time know that it may
not be you know an absolute time but at
least is this recursive function and
there that space so axiom 5 is that
there's a statistic of space which is
basically what's described in this image
where I count I take at each step
basically I found a statistic that in
dimension 1 on the line segment holds to
hypercubes and the reason I looked at
hypercubes is because only hypercubes
can tile absolutely like I can only I'm
regularly like if you take tetrahedra
and you can't tile with regular
tetrahedra at all dimensions and and
fill the plane for lattices and so
basically I was looking at a series of
hypercube recurring on itself
so in dimension 0 would actually be a
point so you know this is just kind of
like wow thinking but maybe the Big Bang
had to state not a big bang but it's the
primal singularity and point at being in
the universe had a um had to state 0 and
1 and we happen to use it as one as a
seed to generate our universe and so if
you like if you so I count whether a
seed is active like here we got a line
segment it's actually um composed of
line segments that's a self similarity
CLL a possibly F and so like in the
middle its active is touching two active
neighbors whereas I'm on the right side
because it's active only touching one
active neighbor at all up you get seven
and the extra energy why it's not I mean
extra so taste six why it's not 9
they're actually displace to the outer
part whereas here you can see is 49 on
the inside this is active touching to
neighbors through edges touching one
neighbor through a virtus and and see
how you got and like in dimension 2
you've got four fours four sixes and 1/9
that's actually shown by this picture
here you got four four four sixes and
one nine so this this picture goes up to
seven dimensions for the hypercube I
basically I think we would have like
take the pong time the number or
possibly give you think upon Qaeda
smalls unit time you'd have the plunk
time number of recursion that we'd be in
a hyper cubic structure that is of
dimension to long time from beginning of
the universe to now and we'd be composed
of cells that are similar to the overall
structure of that and that's how I hope
to make kool-aid man president by um by
the next couple years all right
so any questions yeah yeah I can show
you how so you want one video so let me
switch
there should be one last video I guess
to show you some stuff in action I
wasn't going to show this to you about
since um Todd was requesting it
so this is um me I was a video I made
internally for wolfram with a friend of
mine see we're launching CAS this is on
rule 30 not here yeah I mean I could do
like I could just do something uni but
it's not related computation exactly
like let and in that energy I want to
put into you know continuing these
projects so everybody have a good day as
you can see I'm moving my finger on
those on there and it's actually moving
to Julia side coordinates and I'm real
time with OpenGL
I didn't bring OpenGL this time because
I presented it last time just because
I'm trying to build and I'm stepping on
to a foot pedal and changing the
function so now this is a new function
and you see I'm changing the UM the
complex coordinates with the X&Y you
know changing imaginary and real seeds
as well as um you know launching CAS on
the same for launching CAS on the same
thing so thanks every day
[Applause]